first episode in I'm already hooked what
a good show I'm already freaked out
Naomi what was it about this story that
really Drew you in
um just that I could imagine myself in
their shoes and you know if I can get
there I'm sure other people would tap
into it as easily
um you know these these couple that have
been chasing the American dream they've
been
um talking about it planning hoping for
it and finally they've got that dream in
place and to have it shaken and
disrupted is just a horrible situation
and how you cope with it and I I think
that's why people will
um hook in like you hopefully because
um you know they I'm sure they've all
imagined a scenario where they could get
this this beautiful home that they've
they've wanted for so long and
so
yeah
Bobby what would you do if you moved
into your dream home you have creepy
neighbors and you're receiving even
creepier letters are you running for the
hills or are you staying
swinging that bat
not bad first and I'm gonna try to
figure out figure it out before I run
for sure
um
I'm probably not moving to a big house
in the suburbs anytime
pretty much a city person but um
um yeah yeah I probably would I'm sure I
would I know myself I would definitely
fight and try to figure out who it was
and probably blame all the wrong people
and
I'd probably handle it much like the
dean does in this in the series to be
honest I'd be really really
um I just really try to protect my
family as much as I could and not and
not run away from the problem yeah I
like that you and the bat all right I
have faith in this uh Naomi how much
secrecy uh was surrounding this series
because I was talking to a few other
people and you only received one script
at a time
I I think it was more than that it
wasn't many
um but that sort of added to the tension
and mystery of it all because we
we didn't know the end and
um and so you know we were discussing it
and um wondering if certain behaviors or
um certain looks you know would mean
something certain lines of dialogue we
were definitely thinking it's him it's
hard you know switching all the time and
it just sort of added to the drama or
I love that uh you and Jennifer Coolidge
have some really great scenes together
some really intense scenes I just want
to know what she's like on set do you
have a hard time keeping a straight face
at all
for sure that's the hardest thing about
working with Coolidge is just trying to
keep it together
um yeah I mean you saw it too
um and she just goes off and improvises
and it's gold everything she says she'll
start talking to
um a background person and and you know
something like oh do you see that man
over there it's so sexy right priority
that's with him last night
and then talk about yeah you know
details yeah yeah I mean she's really I
mean it's really fun to work with
somebody like that because they're just
really present moment and what's
happening around you and so you just
sort of it's good it encourages you to
just forget what you think you're there
for what you think you're supposed to
say and just stay on your toes yeah and
just take in what she's very present
persons you know she just she takes
everything that's going on around her in
and comments on it and uh that's a
pretty that's a pretty fun way to work
it's not it's not the usual way to work
yeah and as I'm getting the wrap would
you trust Jennifer to be your realtor in
real life
to sell my house or to find me a house
to buy do what to find you a house
buy me a house yeah I would absolutely
yeah uh yeah
I think I'd be more interested in having
her sell my house she's a good seller
yeah she's a good salesman for sure
that's amazing so nice talking to both
you congratulations